okay folks thanks everybody for coming
it's great to have a good crowd here
this is our final this is the Yale
Center for module and policies final
speaker of the year so this is this is
our grand finale thanks everybody for
figure and especially those of you at oz
we came to all of our speakers so it's
really great to have this kind of
commitment from post and we will have
other great speakers next semester what
I promise you none of them will surpass
Sarah break off who is our speaker today
so so I just want to say a little bit
about Sarah hub for before I turn it
over her now I probably most of you
remember the the ruse that President
Bush tried to pull on us all about
convincing us that he was a texting when
in fact he's from New England and he oh
he had me he had the cowboy hats and the
ranch and he owned the texas rangers and
a lot of it you know this guy Texan so I
don't wanted to point everybody here but
but Sarah is actually pulling a
similarly elaborate ruse I'm surprised
you don't know this you're acting like a
financial Joe yeah so um so Sarah chick
she got her JD at pole pole so the bouts
far west you can go and she's now she
now at the University of Colorado and
she teaches or researchers in in public
land fall in natural resource ball in
Native American ball and actually wrote
one of the co-wrote authored one of the
leading texts on on indian wall and she
um she serves on the board of a couple
of grand canyon trust and the another
which they actually had this week at the
Grand Canyon trust and the Western
research the Western resource advocates
so you can be forgiven for thinking that
Sarah is a you know a born Westerner it
with all of these Western issues in fact
she is from Englewood New Jersey which I
and it gets worse she is also a Yale
graduate so she has two things at least
in common with the president but unlike
the president if I can say this she has
at least one market distinction while
she was at Yale which is that she was
the captain of the cross country team
and is actually a very distinguished
runner so so she's got something sort of
marking her presence here beyond just
becoming president eventually um but but
alas she did leave and she went west and
she has now taken on this um this guise
of a of a westerner but i but i assure
you she is truly an expert it's not it's
not just a ruse and and I think you will
probably know that from the top that
she's going to give now so without any
further introduction on Sarah Craig off
Thank You Josh that is the most
entertaining introduction I've ever
received and I I do have a term for
myself and we did not plan this um but I
am what we call in my region a
transvestite and I'm not the only one
there's there's a bunch of us um so I
want to thank Doug Kaiser who couldn't
be here but he has a very good reason
for not being able to be here for
inviting me and I want to thank Josh and
Suzanne for being such excellent hosts
they really helped a lot with my visit
and have been a pleasure to be with
while I'm here and also the students
I've met so far it was really great to
talk to you and to run with some of you
this afternoon and I've just had a great
time I hope it's not going to end now
but I did I was here as an undergrad so
i've also been excessively indulging in
nostalgia wandering around the campus
and looking at all the cute little
undergrads and thinking about i'm
wondering why they listened to the same
music i did more than 25 years ago but
that's another issue ok so the title for
my book came about because i was
struggling to come up with the right
metaphor for climate change and
implications for our actions and
responsibilities I now somewhat
disenchanted
with the title and I can explain a
little bit more if you want in the QA
why I'm disenchanted and maybe we can
have a contest and you can help me come
up with a new title but we'll set that
aside for now the important thing is to
explain the search for the metaphor
rather than defend the title itself
which is which is parenting the planet
you're a very educated audience so I'm
going to assume a couple things I'm
going to assume I don't need to
summarize the scientific conclusions
about how human activity is causing
global average surface temperatures to
rise that's correct okay good so this is
one way in which we're all different
from the former president atrocious
described okay we all know that climate
change is happening the cause is working
a minute center okay good and I'm also
going to assume that you don't need me
to go into any detail about the many
existing and likely effects of climate
change right including melting sea ice
acidification the ocean it's sort of sad
that we can just like talk about these
horrible effects on its way blah blah
you're all familiar with them good okay
so I'm going to dispense with what I
sometimes called the climate change
testimonial which used to be part 1 of
every law review article on the subject
because when we all started writing
about this we actually had to do
convincing not that we were in the best
position to do this but you know it had
to start with this is real it's
happening and now here's my sort of
legal point so I'm gonna dispensable
with all of that and I won't show you
any pictures of polar bears on ice caps
and oh wait except I will there's the
mandatory manipulative photo polar bears
on I'm melting ice I told Doug once that
it's actually you might you all may not
know this it's actually illegal to show
a slide show about climate change
without pictures of polar bears and like
all laws there's a rationing of effect
so now you have to show more than one so
here's a mandatory manipular photo of
anthropomorphic we cute polar bears and
then because I'm here this is the Yale
color bear looks thoughtful and
pondering his fate and big ideas and
then this is the new jersey culinary
stealing something and the law was
recently amended this is about the only
big movement in climate change
legislation now it's also mandatory to
include pictures of pyka these are the
small and also very cute fluffy critters
that are disappearing from my region my
new region the Rocky Mountain West so
there's a mandatory adorable taika
there's the Yale pyka staring wistfully
there's the rude New Jersey pay down
yelling or something out of the movies
game okay um so so you all understand
why our planet is warming up what that
means at least in broad outline form for
our natural systems other species and
future generations and I'm going to make
one last assumption which is that you
also know that while climate change is
the most obvious environmental challenge
of global implications it's not the only
one Global rates of species and
biodiversity loss fisheries decline
fresh water depletion and again sir said
we could just really zop in a list these
are other challenges we face that have
global scale causes and effects so that
that's also true right now I have to go
over all that and here's one interesting
and somewhat depressing slide that just
summarizes all of that this is actually
from a book by Gus Speth called the
bridge of the end of the world and he
got these slides from someone else I'm w
Stefan at all so that's where you can
find those and you can find them online
you want and they're really interesting
and it's just you know all this is these
are all different rates of things
happening paper consumption motor
vehicle transport I'm in here is about
the Industrial Revolution you can see
the climate change slides up there
atmospheric co2 concentration average
surface temperatures you know so these
are just summaries of all these kinds of
global environmental problems that that
we're facing and future generations
will face okay so for all these reasons
but in particular due to climate change
Nobel Prize winner paul crutzen and
other scientists but i think he was the
first one to use the term have labeled
this the era of the Anthropocene and I
know my friend Jed pretty was here the
other day he was using the same term and
it's one it's not unique to mirror to
him scientists started using it so it's
the time it's not really a geologic era
but scientists are using this term to
just describe this as the time of
ubiquitous human influence on the earth
systems acknowledging this that from the
depths of the oceans to the height of
the atmosphere and from the smallest
creature cellular creature to the
largest charismatic megafauna we have
and will continue to indelibly shape and
infiltrate the natural world that's the
starting point for my search for a
metaphor and I decided on the parent
metaphor for several reasons some of
which may not be obvious and perhaps
that reveal more about my dark nature
than they do about much else so first
being a parent is a and my own mother's
here so it's funny to say this with her
here but being a parent is inherently
tragic a parent's best possible outcome
is not to know how everything turns out
if you do know the end of the story it's
inevitably an awful one because it means
your child pre-deceased you and that's
every parent's worst nightmare what we
hope is to die before they do so it's
all up to us and yet we can't predict or
dictate the outcomes all we can do I
could have just skipped that page and
maybe you would have preferred it okay
this aspect of being a parent which
simply mirrors the tragic aspects of
life generally everyone dies so in fact
we don't know the end of any story
except our own seemed analogous to our
situations as human beings on a warming
planet and that even if we do our best
to mitigate climate change which is a
very big if at this point the primary
beneficiaries will be other species and
future generations we will not know the
end of the story and not only that we
will have reined in our tendencies
toward pointless hedonism for them more
than for us so like parents another
words we will set aside childish things
for the sake of others even though the
very best outcome for us will be not to
know how it all turns out in addition
the effort to raise another human being
is an unrelenting lesson in the paradox
of control on one hand you completely
dominate your children and the utter
vulnerability and dependence of one's
own child is one of the most moving and
frightening things about the enterprise
at the same time this creature remains
stubbornly her own person with her own
mind her own consciousness and her own
agency like parents in the Anthropocene
we as a species are in the driver's seat
at this point choice is to manage nature
to let nature be to continue to emit
greenhouse gases to move to a zero
carbon economy all our actions that
perpetuate our influence and control one
way or the other the act no act
distinction is that it's least
defensible in this context given that we
have created the blueprint according to
which all subsequent choices will be
carried out at the same time so very
many things remain completely beyond our
control we have and will continue to
influence the fate of the planet but to
quote the famous sage and philosopher
Willy Wonka there's no earthly way of
knowing which direction we are going
that's the gene Wilder version of chilly
so it's all up to us and yet we can't
predict or dictate the outcomes all we
can do is make choices that reflect our
values and acne the best we can hope for
the best and then move along so another
thing I like about the metaphor was that
it was situated in larger framework of
developmental stages developmental
psychology describes the different
states of human psychological
development in terms of their essential
conflicts and corresponding essential
virtues the essential conflicts children
face are very different from those faced
by adolescents parents the middle-aged
and the elderly each stage requires its
own tools in order to face life's
challenges successfully or even more
basically simply to know what the heck
is going on and it seemed to me that the
early discussions about
a change and other global environmental
problems were making lots of category
mistakes about how to think about it and
what to do because they had not faced up
to the stage we are in so just one quick
example is you know I think early on and
we've moved way past this but there was
just the hope that we could you know
pass a few laws and make a few
technological changes and we'd be able
to fix climate change just like putting
scrubbers on power plants fixed to a
large extent certain kinds of sulfur
dioxide and other emissions right and
there just isn't that that kind of you
know easy legal and technological fix to
something that you know every single one
of our actions every day is implicated
in right so feel like we just needed to
deal with that in order to figure out
what the best path would be so you know
it's good to know where you are and the
metaphor developmental stages and the
choice of the parent stage was a way to
call attention directly to where we are
at what that means about the virtues we
might try to cultivate and the
implications for our choices one way or
the other okay with that framing what
the rest of the book does so that that
explains the title right was this search
to try to just like zero in on where are
we how does the Anthropocene affect the
choices we make how will you see
ourselves in relation to the nonhuman
world and that maybe if we just make
those first two steps it will be sort of
liberating and we can be a little more
creative than we've been so far in terms
of figuring out what to do you know we
won't be stuck with I think what I think
we're sort of a bunch of false
dichotomies pre Anthropocene okay so the
rest of the book moves in the following
way part one briefly sets the stage by
describing inlay persons terms the
scientific and social forces that have
brought us to this era so the parts i've
mainly skipped over with you and the
dominant ways of understanding it that
both assist and restrict us in terms of
how to respond and then the next part
consists of place-based examinations of
how this relationship is already being
worked out on the ground in a variety of
settings so how are we managing our
relationship with the non
world in the anthracene we are already
doing it in a range of ways and I know
if you were you read a couple of
chapters one of which was from that part
of the book and for example for those of
you who didn't one chapter examines one
of our iconic natural places the Grand
Canyon National Park and describes how
intensely managed both the human and
non-human populations are and have
always been and yet how the place its
creatures its mysteries secrets and
dangers remain and many important
respects utterly beyond our control
these chapters also describe how choices
about managing nature inevitably also
reflect dominant values in other spheres
of social and political life including
the rights of other human communities
ideas about the highest and best uses of
property and visions or lack thereof of
freedom and equality so not only are we
not apart from nature in the
Anthropocene and arguably have never
been apart from nature but our ideas
about how to carry out the human nature
relationship are never separate from our
ideas about how to order society
generally so that's the second part of
the book and the grand cane is just one
of the places and communities that I
should examine in detail the third part
sets out a few ideas about how to manage
our relationship with a nonhuman world
in ways that may match the central
conflicts of the Anthropocene so it's
sort of more forward-looking and it
sounds that sounds sort of cheery and
normative and I suppose it is and it's a
bit of reaction formation to my
otherwise tragic few things so what I'm
going to read to you next is a short
excerpt from this last part of the book
it's also the least well developed and
so I apologize for that but really do
welcome your thoughts and reactions when
when I'm done and so the chapter this
the part that I'm a read to you is from
a chapter that is called for now so all
titles are always up in the air but for
now the title is called off the grid and
on the path off the grid and on the path
we don't know many things about climate
change in its effects but one thing we
know for certain is
things will be on the move plants will
be found in new places species will
relocate on their own or with our
assistance glaciers will recede
coastlines will shift if we're lucky
most of these moves will happen slowly
if we're not lucky many will be sudden
and dramatic things will break and sink
and we'll never see them again like that
ice sheet in Antarctica slower fast
though things will be moving this will
not be an entirely new state of affairs
things are always moving water mounts
off of snowpack in the mountains and
travels through canyons and valleys to
the sea butterflies migrate from Mexico
to points north and back or at least I
do for now salmon make their incredible
journey from high alpine clear water
streams to the depths of salty oceans
and back movement is in this way is not
even new for human communities and their
ancient as well as contemporary examples
what are Phoenix and Florida snowbirds
other than people who migrate according
to the weather living in places
seasonally so their bodies don't have to
look so hard to fight the temperature
what are immigrants from south of the
border or across the ocean if not
seekers of better material conditions to
support themselves and their families
given the predominance of movement in
the world it's strange that most of our
natural resources and environmental laws
create reinforce or at least must work
within static boundaries rectangles were
the basis of our system of land surveys
and even the lumpier shapes of American
private property have hard and fast
lines around them demarcating ownership
and use county states and of course
countries have even firmer dividing
lines in recent years voices from within
geography and environmental studies
departments as well as nonprofit groups
have argued for eco regionalism to
replace the given cartographic state of
affairs and in some marginal marginal
ways the law has responded the
Endangered Species Act requires
protection of endangered and threatened
species wherever they are and so it's
regulations reach across public and
private lands creating a de facto if
hotly contested by a regional approach
conservation easements and similar legal
tools also slightly undermine the static
boundaries of
while the exterior borders remained
intact in a conservation easement
scenario and they do allow for layered
ownership of ecological and cultural
functions of property and one might even
suggest the National Environmental
Policy Act nudges us toward a broader
eco regional understanding of land use
because it requires assessments of the
environmental impacts of major federal
action regardless of property ownership
or land status environmental assessments
and environmental impact statements
often examine an entire watershed the
migratory patterns of a species and
other ecological paths regardless of who
owns the land or where the geopolitical
boundaries lie but despite these gradual
erosion of the geometric approach grids
enclosures and boundaries remain the
dominant paradigm but what if we thought
about knowing and managing the earth and
its creatures in a different way
according to how humans actually move
across it or used to before cars and
planes what if paths and tracks rather
than bounded acres to find our
relationships and responsibilities to
the land what if a rivers flow rather
than its quantities of water or
coincidental location within a state
dictated our obligations to it it's this
concept moving from the grid to the path
so I hope some of you at least thought
it was that the energy grid which it's
not and that I want to explore here
first I'll describe a few paradigms for
this way of thinking and then I'll spend
just a little bit of time discussing how
we might adjust our legal and
bureaucratic machinery to make these
sorts of approaches possible or at least
more more possible Aboriginal Australian
cultures and religions center on what
Westerners have translated as the
dreaming the dreaming is a time during
which the ancestors of all living
creatures journeyed across the land and
all of its features leaving behind their
path known as dreaming tracks or
sometimes also known as song lines as
the Dreaming ancestors created features
in the landscape so that's that's the
path there that
track there along these routes they
connected landscapes people and
supernatural beings across time and
space as they travel the Dreaming
ancestors taught human beings all there
is to be known and in that respect the
Dreaming is the law in an Aboriginal
culture that's they refer to it as the
law The Dreaming is not understood as a
distinct period of time but rather as a
dynamic reality that is constantly being
revealed through collective expressions
such as ritual performances and in daily
personal experience including dreams and
while the Dreaming encompasses all of
the many different aspects of the
creation period and it's aftermath
dreaming tracks are one of the main
expressions of the dreaming so dreaming
tracks are how Aboriginal people know
the land and also how they define their
relationships with other human
communities as one writer put it The
Dreaming tracks or boundaries but not in
anglo or European sense and here I'm
quoting this other author dreaming
travels are celebrated in song dance
story and ritual to say that there are
boundaries is to say that there are
differences the universe is not uniform
unlike European maps on which boundaries
are lines that divide dreaming tracks
connect the points on the landscape
showing relationships between points
these are the boundaries that unites the
fact that a dreaming demarcates
differences along the line is important
to creating variation but ultimately
attract by its very existence the
markets are coming together dreaming
tracks man our paths through a geography
that tell what we might think of as a
creation story located in specific
places along the tracks Aboriginal
people know the landscapes through these
tracks and can sing the stories and law
of the land as they travel across it and
encounter its features and this so this
is something very real I mean this is
part of Aboriginal traditional
ecological knowledge and I have never
been to Australia but if you read
descriptions of people traveling and
there are a lot of them including
perhaps most famously a book by Bruce
Chatwin actually called songlines and
there is you know you
you could be walking along with someone
along the Dreaming track and they they
can recite to you you know every the
significance and meaning of every single
feature a lot of map path so they know
the landscape through these tracks can
sing the stories as they travel and
encounter its features including water
and Paul's rock art cliffs mountains
valleys and other natural as well as
cultural artifacts on one hand dreaming
tracks or song lines seem like a very
different way of relating to the land
then what's typical in our lawn culture
we think of and in many ways have a
relationship to land in terms of large
exterior boundaries of places so we say
things like I love to visit and hike in
Yosemite right or Canyonlands is my
favorite national park and when we're
conducting surveys to determine whether
lands qualify as wilderness or
wilderness study areas we look at tracks
of 5,000 acres and decide if there are
too many human disturbances within a
track and then we have to exclude it
right so we're used to thinking and even
talking about land in these chunks
acreage not pass but I think if we think
about how we actually personally relate
to places that we travel through at
human as opposed to vehicular speed we
probably engage with them according to a
path or a track when we walk across
cities we experience them physically and
visually as pads not as grids or blocks
when we hike or backpack we know see and
experience what we can from our from
where our footsteps are we don't
actually experience the Tetons we may
describe it that way and our photographs
may make it seem as if we've related to
the entire space but we've actually had
a much more intimate relationship with
what our boots could cover what our eyes
could see what we could touch the water
we could pump the animals we surprised
or that fled from us before we could see
them so I think at some level the idea
of dreaming tracks or solid lines is
very intuitive it's about knowing and
relating to the land and places around
us that we can actually perceive and
when i first started reading about this
i thought i started to think about my
own song
I run a fair amount is you already heard
um and there are loops from my house
that I think and I don't mean to be glib
about it but in some sense or my
dreaming tracks I know every twist and
turn every Boulder every prairie dog
town the places where the red-winged
blackbirds will swoop down on me and
springtime when they're nesting the
place where the homeless people gather
when the weather is warm to laugh and
joke and share stories right and I'd bet
you if you start thinking this way
you'll think about your own dreaming
tracks they also dreaming tracks have
their analog in many American Indian
cultures like our Aboriginal peoples
many American Indian tribes have
religions and cultures and
spiritualities that are grounded in
relationships with particular places the
land and its resources are integral to
their worldview and their obligations to
the land are carried out in daily
seasonal and annual ceremonies it's
often been difficult to translate these
relationships into anglo-american
property or natural resources law
songlines and their equivalent in
American Indian cultures are read
instead as attempts to assert broad and
exclusive property ownership over vast
swathes of public lands this
misunderstanding is most obvious in
legal battles over sacred sites on
public lands in which the courts have
often fretted that the tribes are
attempting to assert the equivalent of
an exclusive religious covenant while
many tribes would probably not object if
their attempts to protect their sacred
sites and ceremonial places resulted in
the return of all of their Aboriginal
lands what they are typically seeking in
these kinds of cases on the sacred sites
disputes is something much more intimate
and modest it's a recognition that they
have deep knowledge of and
responsibility to particular places and
that religion requires them to honor and
take care of these places whether they
are set aside or not in vast tracts and
so I think if you think of at least some
of the native sacred sites cases as
claims to the US or more dreaming tracks
kind of idea then the fact that they
continually lose in court it's all the
more poignant because i think it's just
this this clash of understanding
what their relationship with the land
actually is that within it it contains
its own limiting principles so to
provide just one example that's a sort
of a more positive example not a losing
litigation battle there's currently an
attempt by the new movie or southern
Paiute people and they include members
of the kaibab Paiute tribe's as well as
the chamber wavy tribes to protect their
assault songs trail which is a creation
story very much like a dreaming track or
song line as chemaly leader gertrude
Leyva's relates the salt songs issue
from a cave on the Bill Williams river
where two sisters camped and learned the
songs the sisters then traveled down the
Bill Williams to the colorado river
where they parted ways one sister went
to the northern paiute and the other
one's south near the old women mountains
Islam California now then to 29 palms
and then south to present date Blythe
California protecting the salt songs has
proven to be a multimedia and
multi-jurisdictional task linking
together lands that are in an array of
ownerships and that therefore require
many different types of legal
arrangements from management plans on
public portions of the land to cultural
and conservation easements on the
private portions and i want to add just
one more example and then circle back to
why this conception might be helpful for
a world that's on the move due to
climate change this one is in the
context of water as opposed to land in
the American West the dominant approach
to water rights is prior appropriation
and under this system the first person
to divert water from its stream bed and
put it to beneficial use has the
priority legal right to it prior
appropriation was adopted in the early
days of non-indigenous Western
settlement when secure rights to a
scarce and seasonal resource were deemed
necessary to further the dominant
economic activities of mining and
agriculture water was diverted to where
the land was and land of course was
doled out according to the rectangular
survey system so for taking water out of
stream heads and watersheds entirely and
taking it to irrigate land that's
elsewhere and then you own the water so
that's the system of land and water that
we've inherited and while it expedited
the extractive and agriculture
agricultural economies of the region it
has caused no end of contemporary legal
and policy problems for reason I can go
into later if anyone's interested but
there are counter examples of how to
think about water and its relationship
to land that have managed to survive
within this system before New Mexico or
Colorado were territories let alone
States Spanish settlers moved into the
area and irrigated and farmed under
governance structures known as the say
Kia's so this and this is a ditch or say
kia that's flowing from the Sangre de
Cristo Mountains there in Colorado in
the assay Kia system spring runoff in
the mountains channel to a central ditch
and parse en tase or individual family
irrigator zeeeee each get a share of
water from that ditch the mayordomo
presides over the assay Kia and make
sure that each irrigator receives a
proportionate share of that year's water
instead of first-come first-served which
is prior appropriation water is
apportioned according to need in order
to shorts us to ensure sustainable
agriculture while there is diversion to
the central ditch the system as a whole
is more path life than grid like the
irrigated lands are contiguous to the
ditch more like a riparian system which
is your system of water law in the east
and and as a result there are a lot of
ecological benefits that flow from
keeping water in the stream and having a
divert and also surprising at ecological
benefits from their system of flooding
which is full of irrigation which is
flood irrigation there are also social
and cultural benefits including that
each par siente has an obligation to his
fellow ear Gators to keep the central
ditch clean and to use only so much
water as she needs so this is some of
the cultural and social so this is
there's an annual ditch cleaning
everyone has to participate and do a lot
of chit chatting while they're doing the
ditch cleaning
picture and the safety of system
persists in New Mexico and Colorado that
faces distinctive risks in these times
of recurring drought and intensifying
competition for water it's alleged in
efficiencies including flood irrigation
are being challenged as a cost that's
too great when urban centers and
large-scale farms want to purchase every
unused drop of water but like dreaming
tracks assay Kia's may have something to
teach us about laws and policies that
will work for us and the nonhuman world
now that everything will be on the move
as say Kia's like song lines are as much
about defining what we know about our
ecological surroundings and how we
interact together as human communities
and manage them as they are about
conserving or preserving the nonhuman
world itself they establish cultural and
political institutions that govern how
we relate to each other and to the
ecological components of other of our
communities and they do this at the same
time this does not mean of course that
these institutions operate perfectly
north at they instantiate perfect and
romanticized green utopia's and they are
human communities and institutions so
there are all kinds of problems and
flaws and bickering and fighting so
forth in the sake is and I and I
definitely do not need to imply that
Native communities or Aboriginal
communities are in perfect harmony with
nature all the time and yet this is
truly their religious worldview right
ecological knowledge and an ecological
worldview is built into their religion
even if like the rest of us they don't
live up to it perfectly all the time so
both of these kinds of examples start
from and allow for a world in which
plants creatures and humans are not
static even if as in the seca
communities they live in one place
they're not doing the same things all
year water and weather move and so
agriculture moves with it ecological
knowledge is the primary and most
valuable commodity and if we apply that
same idea across the landscape we could
manage it in a way that allowed us to
have a relationship with the many
species and in some
even inanimate entities that will be on
the move in the Anthropocene so what I
want us to imagine is an entirely new
set of maps compose the boundaries that
connect places based on where we travel
and what we know about those routes and
overlaid by other boundaries based on
watersheds and riparian areas and
knowledge of how aquifers recharge just
for one example once we have those maps
we can conceive of what our obligations
to those places their features and their
creatures might be composing the maps
will incorporate ancient knowledge like
that held by indigenous peoples and
others like farmers ranchers and
backpackers and it can be a big tent in
terms of Islay as the knowledge but also
entirely modern knowledge from remote
sensing systems contemporary hydrology
etc right all the technologies we have
at our disposal to tell us where things
actually are and how they're moving
including carbon dioxide right among
other things constructing these legal
relationships does not have to be
entirely old or entirely new either the
law of dreaming tracks can be pieced
together with the new sticks in the
property rights bundle that have been
formulated in the era of conservation
easements and tradable development
rights and so forth a safety is
democratic and quasi riparian governance
structure can be married with John
Wesley Powell's prescient ideas about
watershed boundaries instead of
rectangular surveys together perhaps
they can form the basis for a
contemporary watershed protection act
that would do much more in the era of
climate change to protect what we need
than traditional preservation and
pollution control laws so those of you
who are students and future lobbyists I
want you to get start on a drafting and
passing the watershed protection act so
to conclude to construct the kinds of
social and political institutions that
will allow us to relate with the
nonhuman world even as our actions
continue to alter it through climate
change and otherwise we may need to
place ecology geography conservation
biology along with political philosophy
and other ideas about our human
governance structures at the centre of
how we
in our systems of governance if we do
that our institutions may reflect the
full range of our values from how we
should treat one another to how we
should manage the planet for each other
as well as for other species and future
generations in short we meaning mean we
may need to liberate ourselves from the
grid in more ways than just one thoughts
questions Josh you encouraging students
or those who want to build big balls
think about watershed protection as well
that was the cheery normative part yeah
yeah so what do you what we're going to
a water sanitation well first of course
you'd have the fluffy language in the
preamble and that would go something
like this that that in a time of climate
change and water our most precious
resource has to be protected and
safeguarded above all else and that the
way to do that is to conceive of
protecting the watershed all along where
the part of the water flows instead of
thinking about it simply as a place for
pollution prevention 441 and or two as a
source of water to be drawn from it
which is then of course all governed by
state laws so so there be preamble about
why this is like an important thing to
do in a time of climate change like
protecting our watersheds I think will
be one of the most crucial things and
you would add some more language about
what we know about changing hydrological
cycles and so if you're committed to
protecting a watershed right and not
just restricted to certain boundaries
you could be paying attention to things
like changing what the fact that there's
less snow pack but the fact that more
precipitation is going to fall as rain
than as snow you know so you won't be
stuck with just the boundaries where you
are you can follow the water sugar
and you can protect it which you will
need to now all the more so for all the
things we don't need to recite about why
water matters ecologically into to us to
human communities so then you would have
to figure out how to draft a federal law
that could describe a watershed
accurately nepo with enough leeway so as
it changes you're still protecting but I
don't think that would be too tricky I
mean come on lawyers couldn't do this
and then you could you could borrow from
other on public land statutes in terms
of how to how to implement the
management language and describe the
various obligations and duties and then
now we're really being utopian of course
you'd have a lot of funding that would
be provided to the agencies and all
those that would cooperate them like
states and so forth and tribes to
implement it does that make sense okay
ah yeah i'm interested in your thoughts
on the relation between indian law and
environmental law and whether sort of
advocacy strategies should combine the
two i know that in the u.s. often
mainstream environmental groups don't
like to get too involved or take up a
strong position on indian issues but
maybe in canada where environmental laws
a little weaker sometimes they're more
willing to I don't know that's that's
correct um that's that's a really good
question I don't know the Canadian
situation as well I would be surprised
if they found it any easier to find
those alliances but maybe they will and
I i do think personally that there
should be a lot more attempts to find
common ground I think one big barrier is
that and I say this as a member of
mainstream environment overs myself and
yet I don't think this is a new
criticism I think the difficulty is that
when the big and viral groups seek to
form alliances and diversify and all of
that they want to just do it by inviting
people to join them and their causes one
and that's not a great strategy and I
can take more about why later people
want to or follow-up of you two when
they find the cause that they think they
can join in like oh yeah a tribe is
fighting a coal-fired power plant
instead of trying to cite one which can
often be the case and they they think
that even that alliance is all happy and
magical and smooth and often the the
folks on the tribal side see it as just
a marriage of convenience like and as
soon as that one campaign is over the
big enviro group is gone and they're
stuck with all the same you know very
serious social and economic problems
that they're always faced with and then
finally maybe this is even the hardest
problem and then I'll get to some
possible ways that there is room for
lots of alliance um when varmint big
environmental groups want to stop a
project they
often will stop a project that's being
proposed for Indian country on Indian
lands and even if some tribal people are
also opposed they're much more aware of
the difficult and delicate situation
their own governments are in in terms of
providing jobs and economic development
and so even the tribal environmental
activists will feel weary and suspicious
of joining forces because when they say
things like you never oppose these
developments on say the South Rim of the
Grand Canyon where there's a huge hotel
where you go and stay so you can hike in
the canyon and now that we want one on
the Navajo Nation side of Marble Canyon
you're all against it like why is it
Indian country that's always the first
no okay so those are the reasons is
difficult to make alliances I think the
first step towards nonetheless finding
ways to join forces is first to
understand that those those are real and
significant and second to have the
environmental groups do a lot of work to
hire people who know people in any
country who live there and work there
and can work with the people in a way
that builds a long-lasting trusting
relationship and there are several
recent examples of that that are quite
heartening and I have to say I think it
makes the environmental groups to their
credit have to stretch a lot to figure
this out all of a sudden they're kind of
doing social justice and poverty work
and maybe they didn't think they set out
to do that as part of their mission but
I think if you want abroad in the
environmental base and get indian tribes
and other groups to involved that's the
way to do it is to end to take it to
heart and i'll just do it in a token
kind of way um I hope that was
responsive yeah
your time article check out some of my
limited experience
there is a mass exodus of young and in
speaking with elders in the community
that was it that I was and they were
really worried about the younger
generation of past events stories like
it and so I was remember where you
thought about how easy yeah now I saw
that too and I thought it's sort of like
the final wave of a lot men in
termination policies coming home to
roost you know in this in this in this
era you know voluntarily right there's
not a lot of economic opportunities or
development and some more and more young
people are leaving and and I think
that's it's a very serious risk and what
I lived on the Navajo Nation for three
years and there were all kinds of
challenges and problems social problems
poverty alcoholism the whole gamut at
the same time I I can tell you that when
I live there the kids I represented in
some cases and coached and others and
and so forth and got to know even
wearing another typical like black
concert t-shirts and really they look
like kids anywhere every weekend they're
out herding sheep with Grandma and they
knew their land and they knew these
stories so I'm life was not great for
them there are all kinds of challenges
but they were getting this this
traditional ecological knowledge and
their creation stories in their culture
in a really real way and one thing that
was so reassuring is any time I went
running with the girls we would never
get lost I would have gotten lost in a
heartbeat but they always knew where
they were and so I say that to say that
it's a it seems to me a serious risk and
and the grandmas who were quoted in the
article or right to worry and it's hard
to know what to do about that so here
I'm saying we all have to get better
said no more about our own landscapes
and meanwhile the communities I'm using
as examples themselves are facing these
sort of brain drain and real you know
relocation problems all I can say is boy
have those communities been resilient
and so you know it's been several
hundred years of various policies trying
to wipe them out and they're still here
566 tribes so that that gives me some
kind of reassurance or hope yeah so it's
true when you're talking about your act
you were talking about agencies coming
together and who's going to do what I
was just wondering it seems to me like
this sort of this sort of policy
approach to water shredders of worth
carries with it some implications
structures which we have if we reach
that point we have agencies
collaborating
what what do you think
I mean I think it if I could just like
magically change our environmental and
natural resources bureaucracy so this is
not going to happen but what one one
thing I think it's just too late and and
I know every administration that comes
in you know someone tells them the last
thing you should do is draw a new org
chart in other words like don't all of a
sudden we label and reorganize agents so
I get that it's never going to happen
but it would be much more functional if
we had one federal Natural Resources
Protection Agency or something like that
instead of for a service bureau of land
management in all housed in different
ones in interior so agriculture Fish and
Wildlife right so if we had if we have
that and then I think there could be a
lot more hope you know sort of what
people have called cooperative
federalism in the pollution law context
in the context of this watershed
protection scenario because you'd only
have you'd have one federal agency with
all the expertise and then they could
partner with a whole bunch more
operations on the ground and they could
recruit the local knowledge of a say
kia's to participate they could recruit
the states and there now you know very
highly developed natural resources
divisions they could recruit Trout
Unlimited and all the NGOs it would be
delighted to be involved in this kind of
thing and then I could actually see
happening and working i think that the
it is a pretty significant problem that
our own federal agencies are so
fragmented but maybe we could figure
that out too yeah so we need
water should approach to me for laundry
Alicia night seems like there's a
dimension of that this sort of like
sounds ecologically based governments
that understand and comprehend
landscapes and regulates responsive
ecological knowledge and then the other
management seems to be this kind of like
weaning making capacity of law the
ability to sort of law answer the norms
the law helps to produce enough lactose
group instantiate social meanings and
sort of teaching function and I wonder
if you mean any comment on that with
respected sort of other sorts of
environmental or a lot of outside the
environment i mean i know that niba has
instructed to a lot of criticism about
whether it serves this purpose very well
with it sort of aspirational preamble
limits attempt to change the way that
agencies think 2 / 22 free this
environmental awareness
promise so I would reflect on that sort
of meaning a pathway of law in relation
to what you're talking about yeah what
your question makes me think about is is
how little of that has meaning making
has gone on I think in the context of
environmental regulation protection
since that big moment when all the
environmental statutes were passed and I
think one of the reasons is that to a
very large extent and necessarily so
what they implemented were all these
technological approaches intensely
bureaucratic monitoring machineries and
so it was very hard for the normal
person to relate or get involved or
frankly ever want to think about it
again right and um and so it's like once
environmental laws get passed they
become something we don't want to have
to think about because they're just
about fixing a technical problem so how
can we do more with them and so would
this be an opportunity to do more with
them to to create meaning and also to
involve as many of us as possible in a
daily way in the kinds of long-term
knowledge acquisition and caretaking
that I think will be very helpful and I
I don't know and maybe that's just too
darn utopian people are just too busy
and they just want some technocratic
your cred to clean things up and fix
climate change and move on I guess what
aspect would be I don't Frank I don't
think I know some law professors think
this I don't think how the law is
written makes all that much difference
except to us in law students we make
read that language you know a few times
but i think what what the laws might set
in motion on the ground except they
could build on and perpetuate and
recruit local involvement local
ecological knowledge local enthusiasm
for taking care of your watershed where
you live then i think we could be in
business
yeah I I think I got sick of parenting
as a verb and because of the whole
discussion that's going on in the media
all the time about different kinds and
flavors of parenting free-range
parenting and over parenting and
helicopter parenting and and like I just
wish we would all talk about it less
just and and so it was partly just event
and associated student with para does a
verb and I thought oh boy I want this is
myself from that on the other hand I
haven't come up with anything better so
so maybe I should get over it and in a
couple years the media will have moved
on and they won't I feel like it's like
a way to set women at odds with each
other to like we're all fighting about
our parenting style and it's like oh I'm
not fighting with anyone I wish they
would just stop making it sound like
they're all these war mommy wars and um
so so that's why but maybe that's not a
good reason yeah hey everybody enjoy
this conceptualization really kind of
reminded me of Elinor Ostrom and a lot
of her work with community-based and
kind of having people gather around
local problem solving I guess sort of on
a maybe overly pragmatic but I guess my
kind of question is how this is kind of
nest and I guess come to issues that I
think you know are areas i'm thinking or
for example there's lots of different
flows and lots
friends for migration so you can imagine
an animal pathways are very different
through some Apollo waterways but how do
those sort of nest and build into sort
of a bigger system but also talk about
Canada kind of trans-boundary how to
kind of build this across is obviously
can you this domestically but how does
that work across the French national
boundaries yeah um i guess it's
challenging the idea of national
boundaries as being relevant or helpful
which is not very pragmatic i I do
recognize that and so and I like the
other examples you listed and this is
just my first first shot at this and
frankly I'm not sure how well they all
fit together like I'm not sure if this a
key example actually fits with the
Dreaming tracks of paths so all this is
to be thought about much much more um
and you know I guess I think in terms of
the nesting question there are ways to
um if we if we if we just start with
this as a starting point these ideas as
a starting point and think about
building on them instead of with what
seems to me to be the case in most of
the Natural Resources law that I work
with which is to start with the
machinery at a much higher level I mean
you know despite all we love we all love
local in the United States and you know
different political spectrum across the
spectrum we all love it we love either
we love states and not the federal
government we love local local food and
local this not a whole lot of our law
actually happens that way and when it
does it's often just run roughshod over
and ignored so so I left out this whole
interesting and somewhat depressing
history of the assay keys which is
they've been around since before
Colorado was a territory and they're at
risk right now because Colorado water
law was constructed ignoring the state's
most ancient water rights right so now
these assay Kia communities are in a
situation where after multiple drought
years they're getting letters from the
State Engineer saying we're cutting you
off even though they're like why we've
had our water rights for centuries but
they never registered with the state
system for a whole bunch of reasons that
you might be able to imagine they didn't
trust it you know they didn't move to
Colorado Colorado move to them
it's not their system okay so we we tend
to start from some level higher up and
we're doing natural resources law and
management in many many situations so
maybe the the answer to the nesting
question well honestly it's I don't know
but if we started from local sustainable
this is a sustainable agricultural
community whatever sustainable means
this is as close as it gets and if we
started there and built up from it
instead of the opposite way maybe we
could have institutions at a higher
scale that would actually support local
sustainability a little bit like the
future of introductory my scholarship um
I saw the you participated of years ago
in a conference realism I'm not really
sure what do you really feel is out
there but it's just a way to name a
compliment new yeah but it seems like it
was I would call for like sort of a
curricle social scientific grounding
scholarship to create laws the new
google has momentum great approaches it
will have momentum within and beyond to
Indian Territory and I'm wondering if
that whereas sort of that is gone and
what your reflections are and what may
be Indian law scholarship also needs to
continue its vitality okay so this is
that question thanks it's a great
question may be obscure to some people
so obviously one of my fields is
American Indian law and you heard some
of that in here I'm but not a lot and
the it's it's a it's a it's a fantastic
and perpetually interesting area of the
law it's also one that you have to be
prepared for a lot of defeats in the
federal courts if you're going to work
in this area on behalf of tribes on the
tribal side and so the fact that in the
lat since since about the middle of the
rehnquist era the the Indian cases that
have gone up to the court have had only
a twenty percent chance of winning and
that that percentage has gotten even
worse in the last 15 years means that
it's caused some indian law scholars to
do some hand ring like what are we doing
pretty much everything we write is about
why courts in general should stay their
hands when they're taking away tribal
powers right if anyone can do that it
should be congress that the supreme
court shouldn't be making up new common
law rules that diminish travel powers
yes we all right about this and all
these really we think convincing ways
and the court never listen so so this is
you know for some people caused a bit of
a crisis and there was this conference
called the new realism where we tried to
talk seriously about what kinds of
things should we be doing like just
talking to the courts is not working so
what kinds of knowledge should we be
producing and so first i think this is
less like han ring and so forth for
scholars of my generation and younger
cuz we started working in the field long
after the federal courts started being
really bad for our cause and so we were
just used to it and never look to them
to be our saviors and defender
treaty rights which which you could in
an earlier era and I think so i think
the stuff we were writing was one more
critical you know was intended to be
more critical of doctrine and two more
already in this vein of sort of a new
qualitative and sometimes quantitative
empiricism let's just tell me what's
really going on in Indian country good
bad and indifferent you know we're not
going to shade it but we're going to
tell these real stories so that whether
judges ever listen or not one at least
we've gotten these real stories out
there about what tribes are like how
they function how their legal systems
function and then that knowledge and
information will be there this is one
good thing about scholarship forever
molding away and some law review article
or elsewhere and also others
policymakers legislators can rely on it
too right so we're not just so doctrine
focused and the answer is it's just
happening I think it's just what we most
of us do now and anyone who's still you
know writing fake amicus briefs to the
court in the guise of lari articles is
you know they're just wasting their time
that's my my sense